how are you Chris capita rich what do
you say to that poll question LeBron
James your one through four or never to
win a championship here with the Lakers
I would say I give him a shot to win
year three year three is you know when I
think he'd still be playing at a high
level and year three might be when we
see kind of a dissolution of Golden
State and that's a big factor in LeBrons
pursuit of a championship as anything he
does in LA yeah I I think at some point
I'm you know I tweeted this out I don't
know if we're gonna reach that for
another day or two because this is just
such massive news to take in at some
point the dust is gonna have to settle
and we're gonna all have to look around
and see what moves or non moves or
people stay input how that's actually
brought people closer to beating the
Warriors right yeah I don't in the
Western Conference I mean look it when
LeBron comes to the Western Conference
it's not a good day for Golden State
but the Warriors you know woke up after
the weekend and saw you know Trevor
Ariza a key part of what Houston does on
the Phoenix Suns they'll probably get
Clint capela back but that's not done at
this point and you know LeBron James is
in LA but they just surrounded them with
like the island of misfit toys like it
it's Lance its Jenelle McGee you're
bringing back in tavius caldwell-pope I
mean these are not you know this is not
the supporting cast that's gonna get the
Lakers very far in the postseason so
right now you know Golden State's got to
be pretty happy with the way the office
is gone so are you surprised at the way
the LeBron James decision 3.0 played out
so quickly Chris uh the speed of it yes
I mean I've been hearing and I might
have been said on your show but I've
been hearing that that it was gonna go
faster than the last one
last one was what July 8th before that
July 11th I have been hearing that he
wanted to get it done I was reading you
know Lee Jenkins story on all this and
you understand why he he was going on a
European trip and I think he wanted to
have to settled plus there are very
strong indications that it was LA or
Cleveland and when I talk to people in
Cleveland I didn't get a overwhelming
of optimism you know from them so you
know it was never anything reportable
but you know the more the closer we got
to July 1st the more people myself
included that start to believe that la
was an overwhelming favorite were there
so why do you think LeBron chose this
this spot because if it's just about
purely winning you know you'd think that
maybe you had to figure out how to get
himself to Houston right
there were might have been other places
as you just referred to the current
roster around him as an island of misfit
toys Chris yeah I mean I think for the
first time in LeBrons career basketball
took a backseat winning championships
anyway took a backseat to family
lifestyle and off the court interests I
mean Los Angeles for the Bron James is a
nirvana I mean people that don't know
LeBron I mean he's got his own
production company Spring Hill
entertainment he's got his own social
media platform uninterrupted his people
that are part of his his brand there
they spend countless hours pitching
shows to HBO to Showtime now you moved
to Hollywood and you have access to far
more people and far more options than
you ever would before and you know
you're you're working for Magic Johnson
look I have my questions about Magic
Johnson to put together a winner nobody
can question Magic Johnson's business
acumen he has built a post-playing
empire that rivals almost anybody from
his generation so you know LeBron I'm
sure is still going to be committed to
winning and I think he's going to spend
this season either overtly or tacitly
recruiting players to come play with him
but this decision was more about off the
court interest and it was what he does
on the floor Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports
joining me here on the Richardson show
what's Colby Altman thinking doing today
I don't know I mean he he's he's in a
tough spot
there's not a lot Cleveland can do and
they may have to start looking at you
know what teams like Philadelphia have
done teams like New York is currently
doing even Brooklyn waiting out these
bad contracts being a bad basketball
team
and hoping that you land on some of
these draft picks I mean it starts with
Collin Sexton I wasn't a huge fan of
that pick mostly because I thought more
teams should have taken a flyer on
Michael Porter jr. but you hope that he
can turn into a starting point guard in
this league and you hope in the years to
come
some of these graphics you're bound to
get are are going to be effective but
honestly rich there's not a lot he can
do to make this team better right now
they're in that worst possible position
where they're not bad enough yet to
bottom out and they're certainly not
good enough to be any kind of threat
maybe even to make the playoffs so I
guess when it all comes down to it Danny
Ainge is popping champagne corks today
that LeBrons out and it's basically him
and Philly and let's see if Washington
can improve obviously Toronto loves the
fact that LeBron is no longer in the
conference I mean how does that stand
the Eastern Conference right now do you
think yeah there's now a I think a
significant gap between boss and
everybody else
I mean Philadelphia is good but Boston
beat them in five games and they did it
without Kyrie or Gordon Hayward and
Philadelphia they just lost two key
players for them in the second half of
the season that was Ilya Silva and
Belinelli now they brought JJ Redick
back and that's huge maybe they can
figure out marquel folks to work out
next season but you know I don't know
what they take to biggest step forward
Milwaukee I love the Boonton holes are
higher but they're not on Austin's level
Boston is by far and away I think the
front runner to win the Eastern
Conference but you know and I report
this a few weeks back there's there's
not going to be any any overt
celebrations in Boston until Kyrie
Irving commits that team long term and
that still remains a question market
where does Kawhi stand right now where
do you think that stands cuz obviously
that could make a big difference on a
lot of the stuff that we've we've talked
about over the last couple minutes yeah
this this is gonna be a methodical
process you know the Spurs as we've
known and anyone that's checked in with
them lately are not in any rush and one
thing you have to remember Hawaii as
desperate as the Lakers were a week ago
other teams are not and I talked to an
executive from a team interested just
yesterday and one thing he said was if
we're going to get really into this and
make a
serious offer we need to spend days if
not weeks digging into those medicals we
need to know if a guy that missed almost
all of last season with with a quad
injury who couldn't play when you know
team doctors told him he could if this
injury is going to be recurring if this
injury is going to be chronic we're not
going to give us what the executive told
we're not gonna give anything
significant until we have an answer of
that question so I don't think it
happens in July I don't think it happens
till August or maybe even September
right before training yeah
pres I'm a great fourth man have a great
fourth appreciate the the the time what
a day it's been I mean the last couple
of days insane it happened that's right
I know so who's a I guess who's the next
Domino to fall is there anybody
significant that that can actually
change the landscape but we're done with
landscape changing maneuvers barring a
kawaii situation well two things quickly
the one is DeMarcus Cousins what kind of
contract is he get you know speaking of
the medicals there are teams out there
that are wondering what if anything
substance if they're gonna get from
DeMarcus Cousins so the pelicans are
talking to him
the Lakers are gonna talk to him but the
type of deal he gets is going to be
interesting and then rich you're gonna
see a lot of guys with some interesting
names get bargain basement deals does
Dwight Howard get a veteran's minimum
deal does Isaiah Thomas get a veteran's
minimal deal you're going to see teams
you know maybe not the super successful
ones but what teams take flyers on these
big names and incredibly short money
take care Chris ever say fourth we'll
chat down the line you got a rich you
mean you bet that's Chris Mannix at
Chris Mannix YS here on the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience